certaines familles préfèrent les
concerts de punk rock au spectacle de
clown et de marionnettes danse parce que
ça peut pas faire un peu ses horizons
dans l'ambiance générale n'est pas bonne
ambiance où l'on n'est pas une belle
expérience pourrait remplacer son band
qui joue ses caisses que si vous voulez
voir balue et les jeans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le week end dernier durant les festivals
seventy seven et ed montreal 800 enfants
de moins de 10 ans ont assisté au
concert d'un mode de fonctionnement plus
relax et on ne peut pas s'approcher trop
près des dessins tout seul mais la
sécurité super bien ici vote berceuse ni
de comptines place aux sons dressant des
guitares électriques à batterie
endiablée et à la passe qui les fait
vibrer l'un de ces rencontres est donc
on est agente à connecter sur le passé
comme les fans d'arcade avec soi même ce
n'est pas nécessairement un cancer que
le peuple ce point que la messe à 9 h
pour ces mélomanes c'est une occasion de
passer des moments en famille et de
transmettre leur passion
parce qu'en fait c'est la meilleure de
cette annexe onat apprentissage je
trouve qu'en fait c'est fais enfants de
migrants disent qu'ils grandissent la
bonne façon j'ai grandi en apprenant qu
est-ce que c'est la bonne musique
il ya vrae apprennent à gérer leurs
émotions ils y apprennent à vivre avec
le monde mais apprennent à accepter la
différence
je trouve que c'est très formateur je
trouve que c'est une super belle
expérience qui vit le promoteur evenko
encourage des sorties en famille dans
ces festivals en offrant l'accès gratuit
aux enfants de moins de 10 ans les
parents peuvent aller à la billetterie
ou dans les kiosques d'infos qui sont
sur le site puis allait demander un
brass rfid pour leur enfant est rentré
leurs informations d'urgence de
l'information pourrait être pertinent si
jamais il arrive quelque chose à
l'enfant sur le site du festival pour
profiter pleinement des événements il
convient toutefois de prendre quelques
précautions
peu importe leur nourrisson
l'important c'est de s'assurer d'être
loin des sources depuis les coquilles
sont souvent utilisés pour prévenir pour
réduire le bruit c'est pas mauvais mais
c'est souvent un faux sentiment de
sécurité
donc il faut aussi ont même les copier
il faut s'assurer de les mettre à vendre
dans le tout avant toute exposition au
bruit qu'on essaie 66 ans il convient de
ne pas s'exposer trop longtemps un
volume trop élevé de décibels portée de
la lotion bronzage et bien s'hydrater
pour pouvoir profiter sans se tracasser
des nombreux concerts offerts cet été
sina bien l'exemple chartier radio
canada montréal